[Music]
we have to be Innovative man because we
would like to survive
technology is absolutely crucial to
Ukraine's Battlefield success
people understand that they are not
fighting only for the business for the
prosperity they are fighting for the
country
the stake is All or Nothing
[Music]
the tech sector here is a crucial part
of Ukraine's economy even during the
Russian invasion last year it's the one
sector that has continued to grow well
the first thing the tech companies did
was to carry on working for their
customers and that's been vitally
important for Ukraine's economy because
other sources of income from exports of
steel or grain have been choked off in
terms of Technology playing a role in
the war
there really is no element of it where
technology isn't at play and I think
you're seeing
technology workers with almost dual
activities serving their customers but
also serving uh Ukraine's war effort at
the same time
thank you
the text Scene just scratched the
surface in Ukraine it's it's gonna blow
up we have to support it we have to show
that no matter what happens to us we
still are able to be operational and
that's
exactly what I am proud of
we have this speech to speech AI voice
cloning system that lets one actor
perform not just say things in the voice
of another so what's happening what's
happening is my voice my voice
and yeah it gets converted to multiply
to a different person's Voice's voice
and I have and I have not just not
gender or gender but also a different
accent we work quite a lot with film
studios TV studios uh video game
creators
so that's the film and eventful disaster
we did together with MIT Center of
advanced spirituality
[Music]
we created a Nixon speech that was
written in case of Apollo 11 Mission
goes wrong Fates has ordained that the
men who went to the moon to explore in
peace
will stay on the moon to rest in peace
we were awarded with Amy right before
the full-blown invasion
as a company we were preparing so we had
contingency plans so we were delivering
Hollywood projects like Kobe one Kenobi
it was delivered from bomb shelters
we actually had several generators in
order to supply office
and Sterling's in case if internet
connection would go down
as well as Sterling's were shipped to
people who are not in queue in other
regions of Ukraine and batteries
generators all that stuff and our drill
was about 35 seconds to switch office to
generators
now is the best time to invest in
Ukraine because those who were able to
survive no matter what are exceptional
currently I'm mainly involved with two
military-related projects and one of
them is this book
yeah
essentially it's a distributed network
of acoustic sensors they're built for
air defense for like detecting Airborne
threats I got connected through the
engineering community to a team who was
already by that time like pretty far in
terms of hardware
[Applause]
[Music]
we have installed the 64
sensors as per now and plan to install a
lot more here's the parabolic acoustic
mirror that focuses the sound on the
microphone and the box with the single
board computer the sound is then
processed by AI algorithms yeah because
like in Ukraine you have we have this
like huge territory which is really hard
to cover with like radar and air defense
efficiently they're they're always these
gaps that need to be covered with
something cheap the AI team needs a lot
of samples to train the model
[Music]
because you need to be recognizing
acoustic Fingerprints of things
thank you
[Music]
from a ton of noises like cars Birds
flies like thunder
pretty much any other entrepreneur that
I know they they do have either like a
side project that's building like drones
or or they're like donating a lot or
their business is donating there's an
argument that if you have a lot of
experience and a skill you know to make
an impact technically is probably what
you should do
yeah
if I travel to Ukraine and you have this
idea of this place being a post-soviet
Eastern European Backwater you would
arrive here shocked to find that a lot
of the economy and the country itself is
more digitally focused than much of
Europe and the United States the
Ukrainian Tech sector has moved Beyond
just servicing the needs of foreign I.T
companies and you're beginning to see
some real homegrown stars in the in the
technology Universe like grammarly the
Ukrainian Tech sector has grown
immensely in the last 10 years I would
say especially following the 2014
euromaidon Revolution where there was
this real burst of Pride and patriotism
there was a lot of foreign investment
that came in a lot of young people who
founded very successful tech companies
to understand how Ukraine's Tech sector
has been so focused on helping the war
effort and innovating for the Ukrainian
military you have to understand that
this is a country that is really
focusing on digitizing its processes
they see Tech as a way of
expanding the country's footprint
growing their country's economy and I
think the best
possible example of that is probably
Michael federov who is Ukraine's Deputy
Prime Minister
is foreign
information
[Music]
so brave one is a government initiative
that allows companies with Innovative
and projects to pitch them straight to
the government the Ukrainian government
hopes that this will give rise to a huge
number of new military technologies that
they can harness for the war effort in
in record time
[Music]
enormous numbers of drones are being
used in this war by both sides for all
sorts of purposes whether it's
reconnaissance or whether it's attack
drones
[Music]
our game changer at this war
we've seen since the full-scale invasion
in February last year is a sort of
explosion of creativity in this industry
Ukraine does not have long-range
missiles or not very many long-range
missiles so it needs to try and build up
its own Force if you like of longer
range attack drones
[Music]
this plane has a model of construction
to make more simple Transportation their
overall time for preparing playing for
flight is about two or three minutes
foreign
this is a test explosion of this plane
at the first explosion ever everything
worked after this test we can be sure
that the battle test will be successful
[Music]
in 15 minutes we can make one win so it
is very fast
very strong wind and very lightweight
you know the total cost of the
construction of the plane is about 200
dollars with all carbon expensive glues
form and all CNC Machining is
how many details have a lot of holes
that's why the plane overall weights
about just one kilo
they maybe don't look as Boeing
or Airbus but for chemical as a plane it
is very important there the quality of
the construction it's a decent Ukrainian
specialists
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
what's happening on your phone yes yes
so what what's going on it's immiscible
I mean you you're laughing like
ukrainians are so useless now yeah
foreign
right now the number of the products the
new products coming to the market it's
really huge
OT is
Ukraine has every interest in developing
its own drone industry one because this
war may go on for a long time and it
needs resilience in its Supply chains
and secondly because it thinks it could
become a real player in the world in
military technology so this is a great
way of nurturing that industry
as a drone UA our main focus is
agriculture when The full-scale Invasion
started almost from the day one I was
mobilized I served in the army
drones are very important because first
of all they save lives
instead of sending soldiers to check
what is going on in the in the
battlefield you just send the small
drone of Separation analysis
[Music]
you have drone that cost five or six
hundred dollars and you can
destroy tank that cost two or three
million dollars
without drones the war will have very
very different character which is very
close to what we saw in Bahamut this war
include all these practices from the
first world war
the Contemporary war of 21st century we
have to be Innovative man you know why
because we would like to survive
[Music]
to see
foreign
[Music]
we are like a part of a woman veteran
movement you can see the engineers who
work here every day creating drones for
our army it can be a big birds with
payload less than eight kilograms we can
create small one and we always in
communication with guys from Battlefield
to have strong and useful stuff to win a
war foreign
[Music]
than loots people
you might think that in a country at War
missiles are still falling down on the
capitol people would be staying at home
they'd be in bomb shelters in their
basements but
ukrainians are extremely resilient
there's a Defiance to going out to
populating restaurants to essentially
trying to live as normal as possible
foreign
these events sometimes do get
interrupted attention air raid alert the
air alert app was downloaded more than
21 million times and it's more than 5
million active users traditionally it
was deciding on the street there were no
model mechanism and we delivered this
modern mechanism like within one or two
weeks from the beginning of the war you
can see there is no alerts in Kiev now
also you can see the map of alerts all
the region where alerts is on will be
marked in red our group of companies we
deliver their security systems for
intrusion protection system flood alarms
fire alarms this is Ajax Hub it is a
brain of a system we sell in 169
countries at the moment where biggest
intrusion manufacturer in Europe and we
are actively scaling now outside of
Europe but the war is not an excuse not
to deliver for example for 2022 our plan
the growth was around 70 we achieved 35
to 40 percent because of the war
suppliers started to worry uh if they
will be paid back you need to relocate
the manufacturing into a safe place
because my factory is one Kiev and
Russian Nazis
but we are very lucky in case of
Fredericks the team United a lot so now
it's not a company is more like army
style people understand that they are
not fighting only for the business for
the prosperity that they are fighting
for the country they understand if the
company grow more jobs like less
unemployment more taxes more power to
the government more power to the Army
[Music]
and now we're seeing in front of Banksy
artwork which is protected by Ajax
systems and our devices over there you
can see it on the wall if someone tries
to get closer or touch the glass the
sirens start to screaming really loud
it's important for us to save the signs
which can bring more attention to
Ukraine this artwork help us to
understand the contrast between the real
life and the war
what is a total uh disaster this is an
unbelievable price to pay however people
who are paying this price with their
blood I truly believe they built a
better future this is not a country
about other drugs this is not a country
about political issues this is not a
Russia this is a new country emerging
country with a lot of opportunities with
smart people we can deliver good
products made in Ukraine design in
Ukraine it was a very important on the
beginning now we take it for granted
technology is going to be fundamentally
important for Ukraine's
counter-offensive
it's not only about drones and Aerial
Technology
it's also about mobile applications that
are used by the military for spotting
and correcting artillery fire
Battlefield Management Systems which the
ukrainians load up onto cheap tablets
and they can give to thousands of
Frontline troops to give them much more
awareness of battle plans
also there's a big role being played
right now by electronic warfare or
anti-drone systems for taking down enemy
drones
what's up
this is a anti-drum rifle because it's
lightweight and it's backpack size any
Soldier can take it with him to the
trench it's developed together with our
partners and as a drone UA we are
helping to bring this product to the
market and actually develop it from the
commercial part
no of course it's not shooting bullets
it's uh it's a meat uh radio frequency
which blocks the signal between operator
and the Drone
right now with the war we have it's not
possible to survive if you have no such
Solutions on the on the front line
Russia is also very strong in
Battlefield technology for the many of
the same reasons has that long tradition
of uh technical education and it's used
it well on the battlefield who's winning
this technology battle between
ukrainians and the Russians much
better
prepared and equipped for this word the
only we can do uh as an encounter action
is to
use resources we have
in more efficient way
unfortunately Russians have superiority
not not only in fighter jets
but they have this superiority in
Technologies first of all because they
have Supply chains from China
and the second point
Western Technologies in Russian rockets
in Russian missiles in Russian UAV
systems
they also have used drones in very large
numbers whether it's reconnaissance or
attack they've taken vast numbers of
iranian-built a low-cost attack drones
and sent them flying into Ukrainian
cities they have not been vastly
successful at hitting targets
necessarily but they are successful at
depleting Ukraine's more expensive air
defense systems if you develop something
you don't need to wait months or years
just to try if this technology efficient
or not
So within one day it is possible to
reach the front line to understand if
the technology works and how it works
foreign
[Music]
government aspires to turn their country
into something like Israel with super
sophisticated military Technologies and
we think about how many products and
Technical products related to miltec has
been created so far and how many of them
would be not just created but also
tested and Polished through the course
of war and those products would be a
basis of other sane countries being able
to protect themselves
[Music]
the reality is Ukraine is decades behind
Israel in terms of building up the depth
of scientific and technological
knowledge or the financial ecosystem
that nurtures these companies or the
exchange of scientific knowledge with
Partners particularly the United States
this war has changed us you see the
death
all the time you become way more
straightforward it is everyday job to
donate right now this water is touching
everyone if they have one dollar they
donate one dollar one million dollars
they donate one million dollars
life now is tougher more stressful a lot
of
pain but also
a lot of Hope
[Music]
I have two kids I'm fighting for the
future
foreign
[Music]
the World Bank is estimated that the
cost of reconstructing Ukraine and
restoring its economic losses is 411
billion dollars and that number will
have gone up since they came out with
that estimate earlier this year we know
from watching the development of
Ukraine's Tech sector that it's
absolutely going to play a major role in
its country's Redevelopment and likely
be the leading factor in just how
quickly and efficiently Ukraine is able
to rebuild after this war foreign
[Music]
foreign